Transcription: Violaine Jourdie
Relecteur: eric vautier
Cette petite fille s'appelle Ella.
Elle est née à La Réunion, il y a 32 ans,
entourée d’amour et de nature.
Elle a eu la chance, à ses onze ans,
de pouvoir grandir dans une maison
que ses parents ont achetée
avec leurs économies.
Ils ont tout retapé
de leurs propres mains.
Son père a construit
l’ensemble des meubles.
J’ai appris les valeurs du travail,
de la bienveillance,
de l’empathie,
de la persévérance,
du respect du vivant.
Grâce à eux, une boule d'énergie
rayonnera toujours en moi.
Je suis une montagne
sous les airs d’un papillon.
Je suis un soleil qui se couvre
parfois de nuages.
Je suis un être vivant,
connecté au vivant.
Je n'étais pas destiné à arriver à Tahiti.
C'est la nature qui a décidé pour moi.
À mes 18 ans, la « crise requin »
a débarqué à La Réunion.
Cette crise a été pour moi
une des premières crises environnementales
que j’ai pu vivre.
Elle a éveillé mon amour pour la nature.
Tragique et traumatisante
« crise requin ».
Tu as duré onze ans, entraîné 25 attaques,
dont onze morts,
et tu ne te termineras sûrement jamais.
Il y a eu beaucoup d’agitation
autour de cette crise,
beaucoup de déchirements de populations,
de peuples et d’hommes.
Il y a eu aussi beaucoup
de familles endeuillées,
beaucoup d’amis que j’ai perdus.
Alors la question est : « Pourquoi ? »
Pourquoi du jour au lendemain,
à mes 18 ans, alors que je pouvais
aller nager n’importe quand,
à n’importe quel moment dans l’océan,
d’un seul coup, l’accès
à la mer était interdit ?
Sans véritable concertation,
sans véritables actions.
Les associations environnementales
vous diront :
« Oui, les requins sont
dans leur élément. »
Je suis d’accord.
« L’Homme ne l’est pas. »
Oui.
Mais pourquoi ? Pourquoi ?
Que s’était-il passé ?
Qu’est-ce qui avait changé ?
D’un seul coup, autant
de familles endeuillées !
Alors, beaucoup d’organisations
se sont mêlées du sujet.
Les associations, les médias,
les écoles de surf, les politiques.
Il y a eu bien sûr beaucoup d'hypothèses.
C’est la faute au déversement
des industries agro-alimentaires
directement dans les océans.
C’est la faute à la surpopulation,
à la surpêche, au shark feeding,
ou encore aux stations d’épuration
mal entretenues,
aux réserves naturelles
créées au niveau des zones balnéaires.
Je pense que les raisons sont multiples.
Mais ce qui est sûr,
c’est que le fautif est l’humain.
Oui.
Nous avions perdu
l’harmonie avec la nature.
Nos activités avaient pris trop d'ampleur
par rapport au vivant.
Nous avions dépassé les limites.
Car, oui, la planète a des limites.
Et nous parlons même
de huit limites justes et sûres.
Et savez-vous que, selon une étude
qui est sortie le 31 mai dernier,
nous avons déjà dépassé sept
d’entre elles, sept de ces limites ?
Alors, si la planète était un corps,
tous ses organes seraient infectés,
ils seraient tous nécrosés.
Nous avons encore le temps de guérir,
encore le temps d'agir.
Mais il faut aller vite.
Je vous laisse quelques instants pour
prendre connaissance de ces limites.
Alors, non, la RSE,
La Responsabilité Sociale
et Environnementale
n’est pas une démarche, non.
La RSE, c’est notre responsabilité à tous
de sauver l’humanité, de nous sauver.
Car que serons-nous quand la Terre
n’aura plus rien à nous donner ?
Que serons-nous sans la Terre ?
Que sommes-nous sans la Terre ?
Je n'ai pas eu le choix.
J’ai dû fuir mon île, quitter ma famille,
pour retrouver ma liberté,
pour pouvoir poursuivre
ma passion, le surf.
J’ai alors commencé des études
d’ingénieur en microbiologie en Bretagne.
Et j’ai obtenu mon diplôme avec une
spécialité de management de la qualité.
Ces études étaient très riches.
Nous avions pu apprendre beaucoup
de choses et beaucoup de compétences
autour des sujets comme la gestion,
le management, l’hygiène.
Mais aussi, nous avons eu la chance
de pouvoir visiter
beaucoup d’industries agro-alimentaires.
Alors, des laiteries, des brasseries,
mais aussi des élevages de poules,
de vaches, de cochons.
Des abattoirs de poules,
Et le constat,
le constat était toujours aussi choquant.
Le vivant était oublié
au profit de l’économie.
À 23 ans, j’ai alors commencé
mon premier travail, ici, à Tahiti.
J’ai pu travailler dans une entreprise
agro-alimentaire locale
et j’ai eu la chance de pouvoir
mettre en fonction mes compétences
que j’avais pu apprendre
lors de mes études.
J’ai même pu travailler sur des
sujets de santé et de nutrition.
Et lorsqu’on sait qu’en Polynésie,
notre taux de dépendance alimentaire
aux importations est de 76%,
et que 70% de notre population
adulte est en surpoids,
on se rend compte que l’alimentation
durable est un enjeu fondamental
pour nos pays insulaires.
Six mois.
Seulement six mois
ont suffi à tout changer.
Je vivais alors ma première
crise personnelle.
J’ai été remerciée de mon travail.
Alors, mon employeur m’a dit :
« Ella, tu ne rentres pas dans le moule. »
Je ne rentre pas dans le moule, oui.
Mais qu’est-ce que ça veut dire,
ne pas rentrer dans le moule ?
Est-ce qu’on doit forcément
rentrer dans le moule ?
On parle de normes sociales.
J’ai appris plus tard, qu’en RSE,
on parlerait de diversité et d’inclusion.
Alors, aujourd’hui,
je me bats pour rester différente.
Pour rester un être vivant
connecté au vivant.
Alors, pour ceux qui le savent ou pas,
la RSE repose sur trois piliers.
L’économie, on l’apprend
très très rapidement.
Même en cours de philosophie, on nous dit
que le nerf de la guerre, c'est l'argent.
Il y a aussi l'environnement.
Et puis le social.
Mes expériences m’ont appris
que l’humain était un levier
de toute transition et de tout changement.
Donc, oui, le pilier social
de la RSE est fondamental.
Alors vous me demanderez : « Pourquoi ? »
Parce que l’humain est le problème
et la solution à la fois.
Oui, nous sommes le problème
En 2018, j’ai eu la chance de
rencontrer mon nouvel employeur.
J'ai candidaté alors pour le travail
que j'occupe aujourd'hui.
Je me suis sentie renaître.
Enfin, j’avais l’impression que
mon travail allait avoir du sens,
que j’allais pouvoir avoir un impact.
Un impact sur les activités,
sur l’environnement,
mais aussi un impact pour les humains.
J’allais arrêter de m’occuper de bactéries
pour enfin m’occuper
d’hommes et de femmes,
pour m’occuper des parties
prenantes de nos organisations.
Alors, de quoi parle-t-on
quand on parle de parties prenantes ?
En RSE,
les parties prenantes sont fondamentales.
On parle de dialogue avec elles.
On dit même qu’on doit créer
des relations gagnant-gagnant.
Elles sont diverses.
Il y a les parties prenantes internes,
les salariés, les responsables,
les délégués du personnel, les directeurs,
les conseils d’administration.
Et les parties prenantes externes :
les institutions, les banques,
les associations, les prestataires,
les fournisseurs.
Mais il y a aussi vous et moi,
en tant que citoyen
et en tant que consommateur.
La RSE ne doit pas s’arrêter
aux frontières de nos entreprises.
Elle doit être aussi vécue
jusque dans nos foyers.
La RSE, Responsabilité
Sociétale des Entreprises,
ou RSO, Responsabilité Sociétale des
Organisations, ne peut pas fonctionner,
non, elle ne peut pas fonctionner
sans l’implication de nos dirigeants.
Et quand je parle de dirigeants,
je parle de nos directeurs d’entreprises,
mais je parle aussi de nos chefs de file
de nos institutions, de nos politiques.
Ils doivent être exemplaires.
Ils doivent être convaincus.
Ils doivent être habités par ces sujets.
Les collaborateurs, les agents
des institutions, sont sensibilisés
aux enjeux du développement
durable de notre fenua.
Ils sont même incités aux initiatives
personnelles, à l’engagement personnel.
Alors, depuis quelques années,
j’entends les gens se satisfaire.
« Ah ! Ella, c’est bien !
Il y a de plus en plus
de responsables RSE,
d’animateurs RSE,
de matinées sur la RSE. »
Oui, c'est bien.
Je suis désolée.
Je ne suis pas satisfaite.
Non, je n'y crois pas.
Alors on me dit d'être positive.
On me dit que c’est déjà bien,
que les organisations
se posent des questions,
que l'économie se verdit.
Mais on me dit aussi que
la RSE, l’environnement,
sont des sujets périphériques.
Je ne suis pas dramatique,
je ne suis pas dépressive.
Les gens qui me connaissent diront même
que je suis plutôt quelqu'un de solaire.
Mais les faits sont là.
Nous n'avons plus le temps.
Dois-je vous rappeler que
nous avons déjà dépassé
sept des huit limites planétaires ?
Sept d’entre elles !
Alors, je m’en remets à vous.
Écrivons ensemble une histoire
pour nos générations futures.
62 ans.
Mon père avait 62 ans
quand il nous a quittés.
Il voulait avec Maman
profiter de sa retraite.
Ils avaient mis de l’argent de côté
pour pouvoir voyager,
mais il n’en a pas eu l’occasion.
Il voulait venir me voir en Polynésie,
il n’est jamais venu.
62 ans.
Alors, oui, mon père
vivra toujours en moi,
et pour lui, je continuerai à me battre.
Le travail, la société
ne me modèleront pas.
Je suis Ella, un être trop vivant,
connecté au vivant et je le resterai.
Non, non, la RSE n'est pas
un sujet périphérique.
La responsabilité sociale
et environnementale,
c’est notre responsabilité à tous,
une responsabilité individuelle,
une responsabilité partagée,
de prendre soin de nous,
de prendre soin de l’humanité,
de prendre soin de notre planète.
Alors, oui, oui, je crois
en la RSE, j’y crois.
Mais pas à la RSE qu’on affiche.
Je crois en la RSE qu’on vit réellement.
Et je vous invite tous, tous,
à vous y mettre sérieusement.
Enfin, je pense que
nous devons tous, tous,
redevenir humains.
Des êtres sociaux, des êtres humbles,
des êtres qui s'entraident.
Pas juste des individus individualistes
qui ne pensent qu’à puiser
les ressources de notre terre.
Prenons conscience
que l’humain est l’antidote,
que lui seul peut changer les choses.
Alors, j’ai longtemps cru
que je n’avais pas le pouvoir,
que ce n’était pas à moi de me battre.
Mais pour l’amour du vivant, pour l’amour
de mon père, je continuerai à le faire.
Vous savez, la Terre,
elle survivra avec ou sans nous.
Alors, c’est à nous d’agir rapidement
pour que ce soit avec l’Homme.
(Applaudissements)